Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
I'm Justin.
History is by far the most well received and biggest subject we discuss here on
this channel.
I've enjoyed studying instance.
I was a kid and I am grateful to have entered into a community of people who
share my interest here on this channel.
However,
what I have noticed is that history is kind of seen sometimes as a second place
subject,
not just among the general public but even in places like public schools here in
the United States.
Not seen as necessarily unimportant but behind math and science.
For sure,
though I disagree with the perspective,
I do understand where it comes from.
The primary goal of the school system is to prepare the general public for the
workforce in modern times in order to keep up with the job market.
It is critical to keep up with science and math,
yet nevertheless.
I do also believe that if society wants to have a population that is wiser,
stronger,
more efficient and happier,
the study of history is imperative.
Note,
this is one of the Times where I go into my personal opinions,
but only because this subject is relevant to,
well,
everything I do here,
the more I have studied history,
the more I have found it useful.
It has changed how I see myself,
how I see the world,
and not only how I see the past,
but how I see the future.
And this video,
I want to share a number of ways that studying history has changed my life for
the better,
and look at how it can reshape how you see the world as well.
So let's get to it.
Firstly,
studying history has made me more humble and appreciative.
History is Nah,
well not always very pleasant.
When you find yourself reading about famines,
plagues,
wars,
tyranny,
genocides,
all that stuff,
and you stop and think that real people,
your ancestors,
even when through those things,
you can get an idea of how honestly horrible life can be sometimes and how
fortunate we are to have the things we do today.
No,
I'm not saying everyone on the planet lives a comfortable life today,
nor am I saying that today's world,
it doesn't have big scary problems.
I'm not even going to say that today's problems are necessarily less worrisome
than the one that the past,
but take for example,
the black death.
The black death was an outbreak of plague in Europe that occurred from around
1346 to 1353 we've talked about it a couple times on his channel and the history
documentaries that I do.
This was one of the worst pandemics in human history and some estimates state
that it killed around 50% of the population of Europe.
Consider that.
Imagine half of everyone you know,
your family,
friends,
neighbors,
coworkers,
classmates,
maybe even yourself dying prematurely from disease within a period of seven or
so years.
I mean,
that's some real life then other stuff.
It's crazy.
It's horrible that happened,
but I am grateful that that's the reality that thanks to modern medicine we
hopefully may not have to face again.
It's not impossible,
but I don't tend to lose sleep worrying over the possibility.
There are of course,
plenty of other examples.
Life in the Dark Ages in general,
the Irish potato famine,
the 30 years war,
the first and second world wars.
Through reading history,
I have come to realize how fortunate I am to be able to eat everyday,
shower every day,
have a job,
have access to medical attention,
have a car,
have access to an incredible endless amount of information because of the
Internet.
I don't have to worry about my town getting raided.
I don't live in a wooden hut and all honesty.
Many of us here in the West Live better than medieval kings and it's important
to remember that regardless of whatever pain or struggles I'm going through in
my life,
I remain aware of these events.
At least in the back of my mind.
I think back to my ancestors who probably worked 16 hour days,
six or seven days a week just to live a very primitive existence with the hopes
of raising at least half of their children to adulthood and suddenly a flat tire
or a tension headache isn't the end of the world.
Secondly,
studying history has helped me to understand not only the world around me but
also in a sense myself and how I fit into the larger scheme.
It is simply the nature of humankind to look out at the world and ask what is
this and why is it like this and then furthermore to ask who am I and how do I
fit into all of this?
Religion and science are both there to answer those questions.
Religion,
if you have one,
we'll answer your questions about the origin meaning and governance of the
universe.
Science takes a look into the physical nature of the universe.
A physicist would excitedly tell you have these string of events leading to your
existence because they understand the importance of them relative to who we are
from the big bang to the formation of galaxies and stars to those stars,
creating the very elements in you and not around you deep within their course
and then spilling them back out into the cosmos and spectacular explosions to
the formation of the sun and planets and so on and so forth.
This story of who we are.
However,
in my view is incomplete without a look at human history as well.
Just as we may connect ourselves to the physical universe,
we can also find a similar connection to human civilization and to our ancestors
and find that connecting to it satisfies our innate urge to belong to something
greater than ourselves.
It's not as if all the countries we live in,
languages we speak,
cultures we practice and lies.
We live were arbitrarily invented one random day a little bit ago.
They're are small pieces of a much larger picture of human civilization.
There are a couple ways of looking at this.
This is James Albert heart.
He was born in 1843 at the age of 17 he joined the union infantry and fought in
the American civil war,
reportedly fighting in the battles of Antietam Chancellorsville and the first
battle of bull run and even met President Abraham Lincoln.
He died as the last confirmed civil war union veterans in 1953 at the age of 109
that is a long and eventful lifetime.
He witnessed the American civil war first hand,
but also the first world war,
the Second World War,
and the beginnings of the Cold War and all the major events that occurred in
that time period.
He lived into a time period into which many people alive today were born or
lived in.
Similarly,
Samuel j Seymour born 18 [inaudible] witnessed the aftermath of the shooting of
Abraham Lincoln firsthand as a young boy and lived long enough they could
discuss it on television dying only a few years after Mr. Hart in 1956 both of
these men were born early enough to have met this man,
Lemmy.
We'll cook lamb.
You'll cook was born September 10th,
1759 and fought in the American war of independence according to sources he
joined up at the age of 16 fought at the battle of brandy wine,
was wounded multiple times in the war and was present at the surrender of Lord
Cornwallis at Yorktown in 1781 after the war,
he became a farmer and lived until 1866 to the age of 106 that means he was born
during the French and Indian war,
fought in the American revolution,
witness to the Napoleonic wars.
The war of 1812 is countries expansion into the west,
the rise of industrialism,
et Cetera,
and made it into the age of photography,
but more notably and personally,
he was one of for revolutionary war veterans who lived long enough to see the
country that he helped found tear itself apart in civil war.
Almost a hundred years later.
Putting this in perspective,
my grandfather could have met a civil war veteran who met a revolutionary war
veteran.
We could keep going.
Cook,
for example,
was born just 27 years after the death of William Hi Zealand,
the last known surviving veteran of the English civil war,
which began in 1642 but you get the picture.
Why is that so cool?
Because it changes how we look at history.
It personally connects us to it.
The civil war and the revolution weren't just pages from a dry history textbook
to these men.
It was real life to them and there was a clear connection between them and us.
I've mentioned before,
there are other important ways of looking at history to,
for example,
looking at how much more lifelike black and white images become when they're
colorized.
These photographs show us images of the past as real as today and remind us that
these events were as real as today.
Another example,
believe it or not,
changing units of measuring the passage of time.
The Viking Age,
for example,
ended symbolically around a thousand years ago at the battle of Stamford Bridge
on September 25th 10 66 but you could also call it 347,872 days ago.
Measuring history in something like days,
hours or even minutes connects us to history by placing our lives in the
present,
within the constant march of time,
second by second,
minute by minute,
and makes these events in some ways see more tangible,
more real.
It helps us feel the lives of past generations still echoing in the present.
We've discussed long lived people whose lives extended between periods.
We had considered separate from each other,
but what about non human observers meet the longer new tree in Wales?
Hopefully that's close enough pronunciation.
Correct me if I'm wrong in the comments.
This picture is obviously recent,
but the tree itself is over 4,000 years old.
If this tree had eyes,
it would have witnessed all of European history,
at least from the perspective of whales day by day.
It meant the early counts.
It met the Romans,
it met the later Welsh.
It met.
The Anglo Saxons had met the vikings.
It met the Normans,
hit,
met the English.
It's heard of every monarch in England.
It was there when people heard of a new continent to the west and watch those
people's descendants colonize that continent.
It watched the British empire rise and fall and stood through two world wars and
it's still around today.
Why do I bring these things up?
By understanding this,
we can better look at history as an unceasing series of events,
of actions and reactions of stories and tales that lead directly to you and
explain what led to you being what you are or at least what you were born into.
It helps us to realize how much we stand on the shoulders of our ancestors.
It has taken some work,
but I am very fortunate to have an extensive family tree,
Oregon.
What I mean by that is I can trace my lineage back pretty far because of all the
research I've done,
I can go confidently as far back as about 1575 to around western France.
I have a strong suspicion I can go back farther and that directly to send it
from a French crusader.
I don't know for sure.
I'm still working on it.
Anyway.
Looking back at my family tree,
I can see history shaping my ancestors and also my ancestors shaping history to
understand why I was born on the continent of North America.
I look back at Nouvelle frogs for example,
and find my ancestors came over as some of the first freshman to settle in North
America.
Why was I born in the United States to that?
I can see my ancestors coming into the country during the Quebec Diaspora.
Why does it,
my family's still speak French natively did that.
I look at the French and Indian war.
Why was I born in Colorado?
Well,
you get the point and genealogy.
You may seem like just a hobby,
but think of how commonly we debate today,
how much credit we can take for the successes of our ancestors,
and also how responsible we are for their crimes.
The latter being,
and especially common topic in political debates really across the world today,
understanding history prepares us to confidently handle those questions.
History is a huge part of modern politics.
Our ancestor.
They're not only responsible for the world we were born into,
but the quality and condition of that world as well.
Many of us live better lives than our ancestors like we were talking about at
the beginning of the video because many of them worked,
fought and died for the betterment of posterity.
No person,
no matter how individualistic and self sufficient is entirely self made though
history as we've established is a way to understand how things led up to us.
Many of us still see themselves more as individuals.
Whether or not you know much at all about your ancestors from a thousand years
ago doesn't necessarily change who you are or what you'll do in your life.
And I don't mean to imply that people who think more individualistically are in
any way wrong for doing so.
I fully respect that point of view.
However,
history,
regardless of how personally connected to what you are,
is still important in other ways,
maybe more pragmatic ways as well.
The third way history has changed my life.
It teaches very important lessons.
History is a very good record book of accomplishments and screw ups.
We've all heard the phrase that those who do not understand the past are doomed
to repeat it and you can go through history and find a number of examples of
that.
I would be careful in trying to do that and I tend to prefer the mark twain
quote.
History does not repeat itself,
but it does rhyme.
But anyway,
the general idea here is that studying history allows us to better shape our
present and plan for our future.
We are separated from the ancient Greeks and Romans,
for example,
by a few millennia.
But we have to ask,
are we really so very different?
I mean,
of course circumstances are very different,
but we are the same species as our ancestors with the same blood flowing through
our veins to have a record book of causes and Effects of people just like us to
analyze and think about should be viewed as invaluable to anyone planning for
the future.
And while I don't share them here,
I would say that studying history has absolutely effected my political views and
how I see the world.
Were there factors that led to the fall of the Roman Empire that could be
present in our society,
could understanding how the Romans dealt with those problems or fail to help us
overcome them?
Are there common themes between the rise and fall of Western empires or world
empires in general?
Are there similar triggers for revolutions and consequences for revolutions that
go too far too fast?
Where does democracy work?
Where does it not work?
Where do monarchies work?
Where do they not?
Why do different political ideologies tend to work or why did it not?
What economic ideologies work and which ones do not and why is this the case?
How different can things be?
How similar do they have to be?
All of these questions can be found in studying history.
It is a way of studying how humans work are most elaborate.
Understanding of the present is based off our understanding of what occurred in
the past.
Our conceptions of what the future will be like are largely based off what we've
already experienced now.
No doubt the future will hold things that humanity has never before experienced
and our world will change in ways we can't predict,
but a knowledge of human history,
what allow us to better prepare for the unexpected.
It may not have all the answers to future problems we've never faced before,
but it can undoubtedly point us in the right direction to Salem.
You may be able to extract more than three reasons from what I've said here and
perhaps come up with Iran and then welcome you to share what you'd add in a
comment section below.
But to summarize what I've said here,
one,
studying history has made me more humble and appreciative of the world in which
I live by bringing me to understand the hardships,
but others like me in the past happened York and by helping me to recognize all
of that my predecessors have done to make the world what it is.
Secondly,
it has given me a way to better understand the world around me,
my place within it,
and to a degree though I am not fully defined by the past and for me who I am as
an individual.
Studying history over time gives us a better view of the larger picture of which
we are apart and allows us to remodel our conceptions of the world and ourselves
accordingly,
which can lead to important changes and our lives.
Thirdly,
it teaches very important lessons and serves as a record book of things that do
and do not work.
There have been many mistakes made and many success is accomplished and the
10,000 or so years of human history that we've been more or less civilized.
Studying those things will allow us to understand why those mistakes occurred
and how to prevent them and why the successes occurred and how to emulate them.
Have you enjoyed this video and found it informative?
I'd invite you to come check out some other cool content we have here on fire
learning like how about some history videos like the one shown here.
I would also invite you to subscribe for more videos like this to help with the
costs of production.
Fire of learning does take donations on Patrion.
The link to which you can find in the description.
You can support the channel with as little as a $1 contribution.
However,
simply subscribing to our youtube channel for free is also a large help.
A special thanks to our patrion supporters listed here.
We're also on Instagram and Facebook and now Twitter,
so come check us out there to thank you for watching.